we got tape is called carmilla right but
like it wasn't it wasn't really like
yeah we put our super oil into that
carmilla
who's the melo fan
is that your guy oh i think he told me
that's like that's your favorite player
i wear the kobe all-american jersey
yesterday fresh food but not the jeremy
you gotta go with the kate cunningham
right
yeah that's cool
that was nice but i'm a being fan you
can't tell me nothing wrong about being
so you're not a not a pistons fan i know
you're a fan i'm a die-hard piston fan
yes that's my favorite that's our
favorite that's listen really that's
your favorite team yeah right i want to
see the pisses win yeah well i'm a sons
fan but my favorite players lebron no
like my favorite team is the lakers but
my favorite team is the pistons i don't
know what that means my favorite team is
the lakers but my favorite team is the
pistons still not sure because kobe
played for the lakers doesn't play there
anymore yeah my [ __ ] died but
i repeat my baby but i'm still a lakers
fan i don't like brian for real i like
brian as a person but as a player i'm a
kobe fan so i gotta hate brian you don't
got to yes i do you can just appreciate
it yes i do you can just i feel like i
appreciate his game but i don't hate him
no more but because him and mello came
out the same draft i had to hate him
just because you feel me i had to yeah
you feel me everybody else just liked
them so much well also isn't like
detroit in cleveland you guys have a
rivalry no no no it's so close we ain't
rivalry [ __ ] lebron was just beating
our ass he's running a [ __ ] rivalry
yeah
yeah yeah like this [ __ ] ohio state
cleveland like the cavs in the pistons
no
this is why people start got no right
that's why people start really hating
brian the deep hatred for lebron for me
then he really [ __ ] this up the whole
playoffs brian don't even shoot threes
at this point in his career he's
shooting from half court he's super half
court like bro stop doing this [ __ ] is
his coach yeah stop doing this like that
we i ain't liking
that was like the year
we like that was like right after we won
that was the year that he went to the
finals and got swept by the spurs yeah
but this is like right after we won so
we also yeah you guys were [ __ ]
chauncey phillips uh
ben wallace
yeah that's two years after
but it was it was the year after you
guys went right yeah
because you guys went two years in a row
we went two years in a row yeah the
second year y'all lost the second year
we lost yeah
but look though i'm saying that's right
after we went right so when you guys are
playing
when you guys were playing the lakers
and you guys beat you guys beat the
lakers right you guys it was kobe and
carl malone and all them it was that
super team that didn't work were you
going for the lakers kobe were you going
for your pistons go for the pistons i'm
a real city [ __ ] okay so that's your
favorite team not the [ __ ] lakers no
no
no you're like my favorite team but look
it's on some [ __ ] like this
this my favorite team but my favorite
player over there like but he's not that
way look i ain't wake up every day
trying to go see chauncey billets and
then play like i wanted to see
78 points in the finals i want to see i
really wanted to i really wanted to see
the pistons have a close game so chance
he could shoot a three at the end that's
what i want to do big shot
yeah like this is my favorite franchise
bosch i'm a sunset by far i like this
franchise i hate how about this i hate
the lakers but i love lebron so when he
went to the lakers i had to have like a
real meeting of my like pride and my
heart and just say you know what i'm
gonna put the laker hate aside i live in
la lebron's on the team and at the time
the suns are absolute ass cheeks
so i said and as long as the suns ain't
in it
i'm a roof for lebron even though he's
on the [ __ ] ass favorite player yeah
i'm a lego sphere because
but i'm a i'm a yeah he does i'm on some
[ __ ] like you feel me brian give my
[ __ ] a ring
yes i don't know how they're not gonna
know him is gonna do it
but yeah mellows are free right now
right yeah everybody gonna play for
[ __ ] gonna play with might he's gonna
go play [ __ ]
get that shanghai sharks contract
michael beasley just got
all right
mike supposed to be in the league bro he
was
nice no he still is mike supposed to be
in the league he's not just here yeah no
he was uh i remember when he came out of
college i thought he was like he wasn't
never bad in the league though like all
right i think he just had years in miami
and like especially the last year in new
york and then l.a didn't let the [ __ ]
run
yeah i think people just i mean he went
through a lot that dude had a traumatic
life and they say
he yeah
but a lot of people hear cases a lot of
people here jaylen brown ahead case
like jalen brown is [ __ ] up mentally
yes he is
i know his dad's a megan security guard
i ain't gonna lie i think played because
of
the mental health issues and then just
publicly when did the press conference
say the [ __ ] was trying to pull his
pants down
i hate the worries more than i hate the
lakers because my lebron i hate the
[ __ ] warriors a bunch of goddamn
bandwagon fans had been watching
basketball since 2017. these [ __ ]
yeah well he's
twice he said it twice
he just said he's a chill with that [ __ ]
that's the second time i'm saying that
[ __ ] but this is what i'm saying dwayne
got brown in his first ring well it's
not even good on the side
they don't want to talk about that
though first of all that's not true that
is no because the first way
they imploded lebron did not show up and
then the second finals it was obviously
lebron's team so dirk nowitzki ain't
supposed lebron in them
dirk nowitzki ain't exposed them yeah
and then they fixed it the next year
yeah shout out to dirk man he's all-time
great caucasian
all-time great white man that dirk
nowitzki yes
he's in the mountains we just had an
argument i feel like luca better though
i mean he's better as of like right now
like if you look at the like where dirk
was in year four he's better but
career-wise dirk's got a [ __ ]
all-time career he's got a mvp he's got
a mvp of finals mvp and a ring i feel
like look that's coming for luka you
would hope so i like the fact luke is
built like me
i feel like luca is like just like a fat
white kid with a dad bod who probably
you know drinks beer and like
he probably has like a mild porn
addiction but he gets to basketball like
i feel like luka gone at the end of his
career gonna be top five players ever to
play basketball i actually am not mad at
that hot take it's not a bad one because
so far
you know he's gonna think like he's like
a lebron kobe type player who a uh who
would you want
you and i were kicking it the day of the
lottery and you guys ended up with the
number four pick
terrible which is the you wanted to be
in the top three in this draft but
uh but they say everybody slip and get
jaded ivy so i'm cool i was gonna say
who is that somebody you like who would
you want the pistons to take
[ __ ]
[Music]
killian hayes that's a bust ass
terrible trash yeah yeah yeah first
round he was a first round pick right
he's like number seven number seven
we picked this [ __ ] with number seven
we picked kelly hayes with number seven
who the [ __ ] is
would you would you
where'd he come from i don't know you
ever seen a highlight before that draft
did you know him before that draft did
you know him before draft night honestly
yes but only because i listened to good
one i listened to uh this i listened to
one i listened to an nba podcast and
there's this dude named kevin o'connor
who's a writer who happened what was he
saying about killian
for him
wow
yeah he had a super [ __ ] hard on for
killian he still does he still talks
about on my killian hey still not done
hmm